[Music]
for years the cornerstone of the holiday
shopping season has been
black friday in buffalo new york
shoppers stampeded at target
and the crowds just keep getting bigger
and bigger this place is packed with
people
and it has been since five o'clock not
only is it a time of sales
but it helps people psychologically
helps us shoppers think oh yeah
christmas is coming hanukkah is coming
i'm gonna be with my family let me start
buying things waking up at the crack of
dawn to rush into stores became somewhat
of a holiday tradition for many families
but this year is shaping up to look
different
what the pandemic has done is actually
accelerate the transit we've seen and
that is a move to contactless
a move to convenience or really a move
toward
digital instead of kind of traditional
shopping experience
so i think that's going to be a lasting
change that we see as a result
the shopping tradition dates back to the
1920s and 30s
when families would start buying holiday
gifts the day after thanksgiving
traditionally this was the first day
that retailers would start advertising
for christmas
but by the 2000s companies were
announcing black friday doorbuster deals
earlier and earlier
target stores opened at 5 this morning
and there were plenty of excited
shoppers on hand so there were these few
horrific
moments where people were dying or
getting seriously injured because of
people rushing into a building some
department stores were opening at
midnight
and within a few years the deals were
creeping into thanksgiving day
by the 2010s the one day event had
ballooned to cover the full holiday
weekend
but around this time retailers were also
launching more online sales on the
monday
after thanksgiving this was known as
cyber monday and it was growing fast
in 2016 cyber monday sales hit a new
record of nearly three and a half
billion dollars digital became much more
important to the consumer
so what we found is cyber monday
actually started to take on a
heightened importance for many companies
thanksgiving weekend
starting with black friday and
stretching into cyber monday
is one of the most lucrative times of
the year but recently appetite for the
chaos of black friday has started to
fade
and then in 2020 the retail industry and
how people shopped changed retailers
across the country announcing closures
and shortening their store hours in the
hopes of limiting the outbreak
add in the coronavirus pandemic and
there are retailers that may not survive
we've seen massive amounts of retail
closings
accelerated bankruptcies this year that
means there's
probably going to be fewer stores and
there might
be more of a consolidation and where
people go
to some of these big box stores that
have been open and operating the whole
time
during lockdowns in march and april
spending slid off a cliff
with a record drop in retail sales as
people were forced to stay home due to
the coronavirus pandemic
between april and october around 5 000
u.s stores went out of business
but even the retailers that had
weathered the pandemic are changing the
way they operate
this year retailers for the first time
in
modern memory are saying we're not going
to be open on thanksgiving
black friday will be open the day
afterwards but on thanksgiving
deals are online when stores open
consumers can expect
limited hours in capacity curbside
pickups
and a much calmer atmosphere than years
past when folks go in a store they're
wearing a mess they're being counted
and stores are being cleaned all the
time but perhaps the biggest change of
them all
the shift to online shopping a recent
survey found that 70
of consumers plan to shop online more
than normal to avoid crowds and exposure
to the coronavirus
but this doesn't mean that
brick-and-mortar stores will disappear
entirely
we mostly still shop in stores even now
even in a pandemic i know folks have
been talking for years about the fact
that stores would just slowly disappear
shopping will change how we discover
products will change
and how these products get delivered
will change too
as a result of the shift to online
shopping e-commerce stores are facing
major delivery logistics
and shipping hurdles this year during
the beginning of the pandemic consumers
were faced with month-long delays as
ports closed
and supply chains broke down now the
question is whether shipping companies
can handle the mass influx of online
orders that are expected over the next
two months
a big reason that retailers are pushing
people to shop online earlier is to
spread out sales
and give a little breathing room to the
ecommerce supply chains
but right now the numbers don't look too
promising the shipping industry is
expected to be more than 4 million
packages
over capacity during the peak of the
holiday season this year
it's going to be really hard to order
something two days before christmas and
have it arrive
that literally might not be an option
even if you're willing to pay 50 bucks
for shipping
because there won't be capacity to get
it to you which
could push people to stores but at the
same time
many have lost their jobs due to the
pandemic this year and may not have the
ability to buy gifts
we have you know around 20 million
people on unemployment
there was a little bit of a false sense
of security that came because we got big
stimulus checks in the spring
there was additional unemployment that
people were getting until the end of
july
a lot of that is gone or or up in the
air
it hasn't really been resolved so
retailers are definitely
ready for lots of consumers not to feel
like buying at all or buying a lot less
and even for folks that have jobs i
think
my sense is talking to retailers and
consultants
those folks are saving a lot more which
points to a little bit of caution this
means that certain retailers that cater
to pandemic living like groceries and
home improvement
could continue to see profits while
those that would traditionally see big
sales around black friday
such as clothing and toys could see
bigger losses
the past year has upended the retail
industry and shaken up what is
traditionally the biggest sales period
of the year
but most notably 2020 has solidified the
trend towards online shopping
as a permanent part of the retail
industry's future